nande
私は今商品開発のコンサルティングの会社で働いています
入社して3年経って
あることを思い始めました
それは
世の中から商品開発コンサルタントをなくすことです
確かにこの仕事ってすごい面白いんです
なんでかっていうと色んな会社の色んな新商品の開発に携わることができるんです
でもあるときふって思ったのです
それって企業の一番おいしいところをつまみ食いしていることになるんじゃないか
いわば
こういうことなんじゃないかね
なんかすごい申し訳ない気分になりました
そんな私が今思っている夢というのは
皆さん一人一人がアイディアを形にして
それを表現できる世の中を作ることです
といってもじゃあどうやってそれをやればいいのか
ということで僕は去年からこんなものを作ってみました
ん
me
もうん
ん
ます
はいというのを感じですね
生活の中でふと感じた悩みだったりとか
こんなものがあったらいいなというものを解決してくれるような iot のアイデア
を
動画にして youtube にアップロードするということやってますか
ただし一人きりで1週間に必ず1個
愛でを考えてプロトタイプをつくってそれを動画に撮って先週してはプロとフル
そんな取り組みを9カ月間続けてみました
今日はそんな中で僕が乱してきた
一人でもアイデアを伝えてアイデアを形にして伝えられる方法というのをみなさんにご
紹介したいと思います
まずみなさん普段生活をしていて
なんかこんなの譜面だなぁとか声があったらいいマンがあってふと頭に思い浮かぶこ
とってあると思います
しかしそのふと思い浮かんだアイディアのきっかけ
それをそのままにしてしまっていてはもったいないですよね
そこでまずそれを形にする必要があります
そこで私が目指した広報が
借金ものボケプロトタイピングです
モノボケとは
手にとったものなど身近にあるもので即興で行う逆のことです
あの宴会とかでこうスプーンを二つ持って宇宙人とかってこういうようなものです
それとプロトタイピングを組み合わせてみました
アイデアがパッときっかけが思い浮かんだらまず
百均に入ってこのもののけをするのと同じような感覚で何かプロトタイプを作るんです
どんな風にじゃあやるのかちょっと例をご説明したいと思います
例えば
満員電車の中で
こんな風に混んでるんだけどなぜかこう使われてないつり革があってそのせいで体が
触れたりして結構痛い思いをする
そんなことがあったのでじゃあどうやったら釣り顔捕まってもらえるだろうかという
ことでこの100均ものを受けプロトタイピングをやってみました
まず一つ目が
銃のおもちゃとこの荷物の取っ手を組み合わせて
こんなものを作ってみました
これはですね電車に乗って之ヲ定定に向けでパーン手薄とあ
幸せ
打つとと転用にこれが張り付いて
自分だけの釣りかをその場で作れる
そんなつり革
おはようございます
はい次が
握力トレーナーとストラップを組み合わせてみました
するとこんなものができます
これが電車の中にあれば通勤時間をムダにせず
筋トレができる
そんなヒントレプリカはを
そしてもう一個
ちょっとこの湿度計みたいなものがあったのでそれをメーターに見立ててこんなものを
作っていたんです
これどういうものかというと
電車の中に満員電車で捕まってて力を受けますよねそれをここで測ってくれて
でどれだけ自分が辛いかっていうのを自虐ツイートしてくれる
それ師が作るぞ
が作りたかった
このようなものをちょっと作ってみたんです多分皆さん
くだらないって思ったと思うんですよ
でもそれでいいんですこういうふうに百均に行っていろいろあるものの中からもの苔を
するような感覚で自分が思いついたアイディアのきっかけをもとにいろんなものを作っ
ていくとそのくだらないものの中からも一つや二つ絶対に光るアイディアっていうのが
出てくるはずです
まぁこんな風にしてまずアイディアのきっかけひらめいたものを形にするということが
できます
でもそこまでではまだもったいないですよね次にそれを人に伝えていく必要があります
そこであるのが
妄想はっちゃけムーン日
というものです
ちょっと時間があまりないので一部だけ作ったものをカットしたものをお見せしたいと
思います
雑にかけてを感じてしまうと次にポラーノこの iotv 忙しい時間に20必死に
なって探し回る羽目になるのかな
こんな経験ありませんか
そこでミスター今彼は iot の組み込まれた
萩かけです
玄関で待っている彼はしては帰ってきた区東観2と様々が投票して彼に鍵を預けること
を促していきます
カルネ新倉動きは気を付けたくなることを打ちがいなしです
そうすれば次の日々を気を探し回ることなくパッと家から出ることができます
というような感じでこの妄想はっちゃけムービー自分が思い描いて作ったアイデア形に
期待ではが実際に現実世界にあったらどうなるのかっていうのを
色々妄想しながら演じて作った動画です
例えば
いつどこでどんな風にどう世界が変わるかでポイントは
大げさなくらいにやってみるということなんです味を捨てて大げさなくらいにある
大事なのは
以下にそのアイディアが実現している世界の中に自分自身が入り込むことができるか
そうやってその世界に自分自身が入り込むことが出来れば今までちょっとした市や三木
だったアイデアをより具体的でさらに実用的なものにブラッシュアップすることが
できるようになるんです
そうしてそれを今度は動画に撮ってみる
あっはいこれ恥を捨ててまあのこれ初めて買ったちょっと違う気もするんですけど
あのとにかく恥を捨てて大げさなプレーにあってその世界観に立ってみる
でそれを動画に摂ることで今度はそれを人にされるようになりますよね
そこで有効なのが
一人称視点というものです
自分がそうやってその世の中を演じてみて
そのときに自分自身が見た世界を
取ることによって
その動画を見た人たちも自分と同じようにその世界の中に没入できるようになるんです
でもこの一人称視点さっき僕ひとりで作ったつけたけどどうやってこんなのとるんだく
アクションカメラもない
しかも両手送っているなんで
そこで活躍するのが
これです
これは一人称カメラピッタです
これももの苔プロッタ移転で作りました百均のハンガーとガムテープだけです
あとはスマホをつけるだけそうするとはい
女風に一人称視点で動画を撮ることができるのです
どうですかこれこれでありがとうございます
たかった
これで街中で動画を撮っています
完全に不審者です
味はせてください
こんな風にして恥を捨ててその自分の思い描いたアイデアが実現している世の中を演じ
きってさらにそれをこのように自分の目線で
も動画に盛り込むそんな動画を作ることによって
そのアイディアを
他の人に鮮明に伝えられるだけでなくて自分自身やその日た人たちもまた新たな
アイディアを
引き出してくるそんなツールにもなるんです
はい
皆さんもぜひ何か日常生活の中でふっとこんなもの欲しいなとかこれ不便だなとか
アイディアのきっかけが思い浮かんだらまず
百均モノボケプロトタイピングで
とにかく何か作ってみるそしてそれを妄想はっちゃけムービーでこんな風に簡単に
伝える形にしてみてください
そういうことができるようになると一人一人がこうやってアイデアを形にして発信
できるようになります
そんな人が増えていけばもっとこの世の中アイディアがいっぱい溢れ変えるような
世の中になると思います
そして冒頭で述べた通り僕は職を失うでしょう
その時はぜひ何か面白い職業あったら紹介してくださいありがとうございました